[musique]
les prix ont presque doublé et
produits et bien, s'il y a encore des produits autorisés
on va dire des choses comme ça plus ou moins
il y a tout le monde et il y a encore des brocantes pour nous
sont sauvés maintenant
pour qui ce n'est pas un secret
des produits bien sûr aussi gros
nécessité
ont beaucoup augmenté de prix
[musique]
merci beaucoup nous sommes tellement moi-même il
gagné notre cet écart lui et
la souris reste ne gagne pas d'argent là-dessus, mais
si c'était moins cher pour nous cette année-là
la politique naturellement les gens sont meilleurs
effrayé
[musique]
pas de travail à l'usine
il n'y a pratiquement pas de travail pour vous à la mine
pratiquement sur un travail de chaîne de carrière
Cela signifie que la super organisation
Non et ainsi de suite C'est très lourd
économique
[musique]